good afternoon
everybody I am very honored and pleased
to introduce our seminar speaker for
today he's Dr Bert CER that you see here
he's our senior scientist in the
division and he joined Erie in March uh
2011 but uh before that he was also at
eie like many of us here and then
returned back in 20111 or 20 yeah
2011 and uh joined our uh irrigated rice
breeding now he's leading it and before
that I would like to mention that uh he
was at the University of Melbourne where
he did his PhD and his bachelor's degree
with
honors and uh from Erie in 2005 to 2006
he went back to Australia and joined Jo
the uh primary Industries in uh
Department of primary Industries in uh
Australia uh and uh became the national
program leader of the durum wh uh
reading program so uh here at Erie he is
leading our irrigated rice reading
program and I would like to introduce
him as our speaker for today Dr Bert
colard his talk uh will be on uh
redesigning Eris irrigated breeding
program Dr
K thank you very much and good afternoon
to
everyone so I think many of you are
aware that there's been an enormous
amount of changes happening in the plant
reading of genetics and biotechnology
division it's probably an understatement
because I dare say that there haven't
been such dramatic changes in the last
years I will tell you this afternoon
about just some of those changes
particularly concerning the irrigated
breeding program so it's too much one
Thursday seminar is not enough to talk
about all of them and I I will leave
some content for my colleagues to uh
inform you about in the future but I
will specifically talk about the
irrigated bre
program first we might start with just a
little bit of hisory
uh I think most of us are aware of that
irie has a very illustrious and Rich
history it really started in
1966 when ir8 was was developed and
released and I think sometimes sobering
to remember that at the time Farmers
used traditional varieties and typical
you know yields were you know several
tons per hectare but after this first
semi dwarf variety
uh
yield the yield just shot through the
roof it was we're talking 6 to8 tons per
hectare and even in some really
favorable environments it would you know
nearly break 10 tons per hectare so this
was truly a revolutionary change in in
rice
production I had to do some counting to
see how many varieties had actually
released uh from the irrigated program
alone the were 45 or something like that
it's sometimes hard to keep track of all
of them because sometimes writ is
release in different countries with
different names but um it's really a
credit to the Breeders and the breeding
team that really developed all of those
varieties so initially from Dr Kush Dr P
and the team the the local staff that
really spend so many long hard hours in
the Sun but it's not the quantity it's
really the
quality and what I mean by that is uh
the some would argue the true measure of
how successful the variety is is
certainly not you know one doesn't
measure how good a breeder is on how
many varieties are released it's really
what is done with them and I've just
selected two varieties which
really almost led to the term a new term
to be proposed called Mega varieties and
I think Dave mckill was the first person
to to describe this or you know this
this term it it means a variety that's
grown on millions of
hectares so we're not saying it's just
popular it's extremely popular and if
you look closely here at this
table just for ir36 that was arguably
one of the first mega varieties of rice
that you know in the Philippines alone
it was pushing 4 million
hectares but the real Superstar
of rice varieties was undoubtedly ir64
and if you just look at the coverage of
this single variety alone it is quite
staggering just in Indonesia 47 million
hectares it's quite remarkable and I'm
not aware of any other crop that even
comes
close for our friends from SS this is
probably the bottom line there was a uh
an independent assessment done by ACR
which is the Australian Center for
international agricultural research and
they estimated the impact of irrigated
varieties in three Southeast Asian
countries and that was the bottom line
there 1.46 billion doar in terms of the
economic benefits per year and they
broke it down per country and you can
see you can you can read this this
report for yourself so it is it's a free
uh it's actually downloadable from the
ACR
website so with that rich history and
that quite Grand history in fact some
have described ir's irrigated program as
the most famous in the world if you and
when you consider what the outputs have
been that is probably a fair comment so
the question you're probably asking is
why have we changed
things I shall explain but first I'll
just keep you in suspense for a bit
longer I'll just give you some
background which I think is critical for
the context of what I will say first
point this is like plant reading 101
first point just so you're all on the
same page rice breeding takes a long
time it's generally accepted here at
irie that a typical time to develop a
new variety would be about 9 to 10 years
so it's a lot of work actually literally
is a lot of work the from seaing to
harvest there just enormous amount of
that operations that are required in the
field uh in front of a computer storing
seeds and what have you so there's an
enormous logistical operation uh those
in pbgb know this only too
well another point I'd like to emphasize
is that by the way this book it's a free
irie book which you can Google and I
used to basically give it to the
particip of the rice breeding course
that was the first thing I would
encourage them to read it's really the
Bible of rice breeding uh I still
sometimes refer to it from time to time
it's a beautiful textbook um but the
thing I'd like to me point out because
you may not be able to see it at the
back is its publication date
1979 and if one was to look at it you
would probably see that little here at
irie and that really represents what
Asia is on about has changed in in quite
a long time so that's the background so
why have we changed now I'll explain why
the reasons the first one you have to
pardon my language if I get a bit too
you know uh uh rough but I suppose
readers are a bit you know like this I
call it the f word that was our
main
uh our main reason almost overnight
because of for cost recovery we had to
change our
operations okay this just gives you a
summary of the amount that was spent
actually in 2010 and 2011 full cost
recovery wasn't it wasn't implemented so
I I basically got the samples that were
in our records and did uh a back
calculation in our current full cost
recovery rates but you can see here that
just this is just the trade screening
for disease and SE quality alone this
does not include our field costs and all
of our other labor resource costs that
are required and maybe it'll just shed
some light that our main funding source
in The Last 5 Years From 2009 to 2014
has been the Japan R breeding program
and you can see that the the cost of
screening alone exceed what we're
allocated from that
project so reason number one is from the
point of view of resources alone I
believe we have to change and you'll
notice also in 2013 there was no
screening done because I had a deficit
to carry over for that year I had no
money to do anything with for screening
anyway that's the first reason I think
it's also with acknowledging the funding
support from the Japan government for
for the Japan right
project reason number
two there have been tremendous changes
within the division as I mentioned just
before
uh in the last decade and and a half I I
think we were something like this uh
there was a very big irrigated program
and that included the golden
rice uh component there was a hybrid
rice which is still pretty much the same
now and I think we were kind of baseding
these tra based rainfed Focus breeding
programs and really the stasa program
has sort of has just uh has supported
those pipelines and there was always
some Japonica work that was
done 2012 2013 we we were transformed
into
this I think many of you would be aware
of the level of restructuring that's
been done uh from our head
eroa and what we look like now so I mean
it's similar but it is it is certainly
different we we've got uh a focus on you
know irrigated and rainfed E systems and
we've really been divided a lot more
into regions as you can see from from
this this
diagram uh I will also highlight for
those of you who may be not aware of it
that we've we've also really uh
decentralize a lot of our breeding
activities as well so for example The
Hub as we call it for South Asia and
irrigated is located in Hydra but in
India and the same is for the rainfed
program which I in kumal in in Hy same
location and there is also another Hub
in Burundi so that's a huge change in
terms of just the the way that the
breeding uh pipelines as they're called
are
organized uh many of you are probably
aware that uh for example you know there
used to be a a drought breeding program
there still is that that is certainly
going on but uh the way we've been
restructured has been focused on
generally separating the tra development
work or the research work or even some
people might call it pre-breeding work
from the actual breeding itself and so
that's that's been done for most of the
traits if not for all of the traits that
e was working on so one representation
might look something like this that
there's still a lot of input they have
into the breeding pipelines but they are
separated and the way I like to sort of
think about it is all of them still flow
into the relevant breeding pipeline the
variety development pipeline so and as
you can imagine some tra teams actually
flow into multiple pipelines um so that
that's how the structure is but again
I'm not going to talk so much about pbgb
itself I'm going to talk a focus on the
irrigated
activities reason number three
undoubtedly concerns with just a change
of philosophy
and I simply mean just new ideas about
the best approaches using modern methods
using alternative methods and as you saw
from the first uh the introduction slide
I mean my background is from other crops
and I've seen things done completely
differently with with cereals like wheat
and barley which are very similar to
rice but of course they they they're
bred in a very different
way reason number four is the high
demand on e scientists and I I'll I'll
actually mention breeders here I I don't
think we discussed this much but
compared to a typical Nas breeder we
have a lot more on our
plate we have seed requests we have and
just this year alone I mean we're only
August right I've had we have our team
has had thousands of individual seed
requests and it's been quite uh
demanding to say the least to fulfill
and we're obliged to do so and and we
want to do so what e is about but it has
been a challenge we have visitors nearly
every every week every day of every week
we have training courses uh we I've just
come back from a mission in Vietnam and
I'm still uh burning off the excess food
that I ate during that time uh we have
all sorts of research activities and I
think it's fair to say that I think
breeders need to be aware of that and my
point is I think there's no harm to
simplify methods whenever
possible and one thing I always like to
give I'm not sure if he's here but I'd
like to acknowledge Alan and the inur
team for really facilitating those
hundreds and thousands of entries that
we send to our Nas programs you know
every
year okay reason number five this is
possibly the heart of the
redesigning uh activities
by this is a figure from I think one of
the landmark papers it's a absolute
beautiful paper from sheling ping and
others here at er and it's quite simple
it just
basically uh describes what we we refer
to as an era experiment so basically you
take the varieties from the old the
oldest varities that you've got and you
include the you know the current and
older ones and and you you put all all
of those and Benchmark them with the the
modern the latest varieties and that's
what that was done so so it was
published in
[Music]
1999 and I think this one here turned
out to it was an elite line at the time
but it turned out to be PSV RC 52 so
that was the that was the data set they
had at the time and the bottom line was
that they estimated that the rate of
genetic gain or yield improvement over
time was about 1% per year okay that's
that's the first point and if you look
at the uh if you read the paper more
that translates to about 75 kilog per
year per hectare per year just to give
you a sort of a reference
point based on irie's projections and a
lot of other data it is this is believed
to be insufficient to meet future
demands for Rice so this is this is
something a very important take- home
message we've actually extended this
this experiment as as you saw there are
only about 12 varieties in that in the
previous one and that was done you know
15 years ago or or even further than
that and so what we did this was one of
the first things in 2013 we started to
basically reassess where we are at this
or in
2013 and so we put all of the varieties
that included in sheling P's paper
including ir8 and we put the latest ones
there and we found out that uh I should
point out I should have mentioned
previous slide that that study was done
during the dry season when yields are
higher of course but we wanted to test
both season this is still ongoing but
we've found that perhaps we feel that
the estimated rate of genetic gain is
actually lower than first projected
predicted by Shing P paper and the rate
of you can see there's a lot of noise in
this in this graph but uh certainly the
rate we we certainly believe C for the
wet season at least it is lower than
what was first uh uh reported by
P okay
so on the basis of that if you wanted
one more reason reason number six is as
I said the Japan breing program money
was to end this year and we we had to
look for an alternative source and the
Gates Foundation was interested in uh in
some discussions with irie about our new
ideas to change that last point the rate
improving the rate of genetic gain and
so reason number six is really we got
money to
do to do things differently we did not
get money to do things as they were done
previously and I think we we've that
previous slide shows about 50 nearly 50
years of of our best efforts and the the
rate was quite linear it certainly was
linear and uh that's as I said we we we
at e feel that we need to do do more
than that so I'll introduce this new
project which we call transforming rice
breeding or
trb it's it's a Gates Foundation project
like many others at the moment uh the
total amount is 12 a half million over
the 5 years and it's specifically
focusing on
irrigated uh e irrigated
regions uh and it's not specifically our
pipeline but it's it's it really
supports a lot of transformation
activities within the pbgb division
itself and I'll I'll elaborate more
during that but but certainly more will
be said about that uh in the near
future uh and just to complete the
picture the the focus of this uh
research project was was exclusively
South Asia namely India and Bangladesh
which are priorities for the Gates
Foundation okay I'll start by talking
about breeding methods and I'll also
this is also the most controversial so I
think it's a good place to
start again plant breeding 101 this is a
a simplified version of the pedigree
breeding method which has been used for
the last 45 50 50 years plus actually in
the irrigated breeding program and
probably the basis of this is that there
is extensive trait
selection during the segregating
populations that of so the new breeding
populations that are developed they
green for many traits and combinations
of traits at the same time as well Okay
so we've got the blast and there there's
several there's several variations
possible but this is just one one scheme
uh so that's that's why it was costly
and and even time consuming and resource
demanding because there was so much tra
screening done and individual lines had
to be kept intact in terms of their
identity from a single F2 plant
what we're trying to do is to use a new
approach it's called rapid generation
advance or
RGA it actually isn't that
new it was first reported in the I think
it was the 1940s can you believe uh and
but it really uh it was adopted by some
programs particularly winter Cals made
in the 60s and 70s so it's not that new
but probably the the bottom line is that
you grow
plants in these Little Seedling trades
at high density with low
fertilizer and in fact I think Ricardo I
think I'm going to get a prize for the
first prop of the year I
show R tra I hope you can all see
that uh so the features are that yeah
you just basically grow plants at a very
high density and you stress them you
actually impose a mild stress you can
see that you know if this was in the
field this would be tillering quite
extensively but in these small trays
where we can find the growth of the
plant it tilling is not possible because
the plant is stressed and when the plant
is stressed we we manipulate the
conditions in such a way that it will
flour much more early than it would if
it was grown in in optimal uh conditions
the other point I'd like to emphasize is
that in contrast the previous method
there is no trait selection during what
we call line fixation or line
development
stage okay so that's uh quite a quite a
big difference although as I said this
method is not actually that new it's
been used in a lot of other breeding
programs but it's probably had a limited
use in rice but some use in r
in okay this is just a before typhoon
glender we had a really nice operation
in vg9 and it looked something like this
uh we had a a two- tiered shelving
system so space was our main
limitation and you can
see probably the the thing I just wanted
to highlight by showing you this this
short uh video is we've got a lot of
plants in this small area that's
probably the the take-home message um
and from that was in March April uh
early this year during one of our first
uh rounds it's Joseph bero who I'll say
more about him in a moment uh we had
about 40,000 lines in what you just saw
and that that Greenhouse wasn't even
full the equivalent area in the field
would take several
hectares okay so this is this is
currently what we're at um uh we're
still doing a lot of optimization
because rice is actually not as easy to
manipulate as say wheat or barley uh but
we're we we've made excellent progress
and uh we've got several experiments
planned or even some that are ongoing uh
and what the idea is is to make this
basically a service a full cost recovery
service so that other breeders other
trait teams can actually use it and our
Target is some some sometime in 2015 it
really uh as I said spaces our
limitation and so new facilities are
being are being planned um so we've
actually taken a few Guinea PE
customers uh and we're seeing how that
goes because the the real challenge is
the wet season and it's let's hope there
were no more typhoons uh this year but
but the wet season brings its it's uh
you know uh a load of of insects
particularly which once they're in
Greenhouse can really um wreck some
damage and for those customers for for
further information uh and if you have
any complaints these are the people I'd
like you to contact not me uh Joseph and
RX will be leading the RGA team and they
they've made an excellent uh start to to
this this very critical stage of our new
uh cross cutting team um and it's it's
probably worth pointing out that
probably only 18 months ago to two years
we had just basically just a concrete
area there was nothing we had no no no
buckets or we we had nothing so we've
come a long way in a short
time some of you might have seen
this
sign um what that's about is well space
really was limited and we just thought
well would this work in the
field and we s well you know why don't
we just try it just just stick something
in the field so
we we literally did that and at first we
were thinking well can we just you know
basically grow them in the field but the
problem as you can imagine is the
tillering and the resources the
nutrients that the rice plants would
have so by keeping them in this
tray we we still confine the
growth uh and and really we still
maintain that that low level of stress
on these rice plants and so this started
in May this is the first season that
we've run it
and if you just walk past it I think you
would have seen it because it's next to
the long-term continuous cropping
experiment it really looks like a sort
of a Seedling Nursery that's been left
to run for too long okay so you can't
you can barely notice but the trays are
there all this this material has been
planted direct seated into trays and
just literally stuck in the soil and
just yesterday this photo was taken just
yesterday afternoon they've just started
to harvest that material and because
it's direct seated and there's that
moderate stress needed for
RGA uh I counted the calendar days
between seeding to the start of harvest
it was 91 days
yesterday um and and I think we can
tweak this system a lot more how far we
go with it I I don't know but certainly
in the meantime when we don't have
enough space in the green houses
especially after the typhoon um I think
we'll we'll run with this um we
certainly need to tweak the fertilizer
and maybe some other you know man but
but it's promising and uh again in half
of the area which is it's about the
total area is something like 400 uh
Square
met uh we had over
260 that's a predicted amount 260,000
lines in about 200 square meters so it's
quite a a really densely packed area and
I should have also mentioned that since
we are neighbors to the long-term
continuous cing experiment we're also
are following their their season so they
have the dry season the early wet season
and the late wet season and just Frankly
Speaking I think irie really should be
exploiting its capacity for multiple
Generations in the field a lot more
that's just that's just my sort of two
cents
worth okay now I'll talk to you about
field
tries again this is a bit more uh
introduction that uh a traditional
textbook pedigree breeding method
something like this you have the
pedigree line stage of pedigree
nurseries where you may have 10,000
lines uh tens of thousands of lines and
then you have usually what's called an
observational yield trial and then a
replicated yield trial followed by that
uh the
oyt is is the stage where we first
evaluate lines usually after the lines
of what we call a fixed and then after
that we go to a multilocation testing
scheme can uh just following on what I
spoke to about earlier it's implying
that there were a lot of other
alternative schemes I just thought I'd
show you this one this is a a textbook
early wheat breeding scheme it's
probably a bit hard to read at the back
but the take-home messages
are the multilocation trials a lot
earlier than what we would typically do
in
rice probably the take-home message and
um I learned a lot of tricks from a lot
of breeders back in Australia and this
this guy in particular uh and he had a
completely different philosophy altoe he
he would push it up even earlier F3 or
F4 actually but sadly he just passed
away last month but but he was quite an
innovator in Australian week breeding uh
cycles and and again just to let you
know this is not new information this
was published a long time ago de
ago I thought I'd show you this so you
can see sort of what what's happened to
me de since when I was back in Australia
I've got a lot more gray hair now and I
think I've aged terribly on the inside
but I I just wanted to obviously this is
not rice uh again in line with the
previous philosophy